Patrick Mahomes has an official second
position on the Chiefs besides
quarterback and it's honestly one of the
last positions you would think of chiefs
punter Tommy Townsend hurt his knee so
the Chiefs had to come up with a backup
plan and Casey couldn't make the game do
they tap into their free agent punters
or do they choose their in-house backup
plan they went with the ladder and that
plan was Patrick Mahomes Chief's
assistant coach Dave to says that
Mahomes shows him all the time that he
can punt Town send ended up being fine
and he was able to play but that doesn't
mean that we won't potentially see
Mahomes in that position in the future